uh
apple slashes app store fees for smaller
developers
sure tech giant cuts its take from fit
from 30
to 15 for some app makers and a wake up
criticism over its power
in the apple device ecosystem starting
next year the iphone maker said
wednesday it will collect
15 rather than 30 percent app store
sales from companies that generate no
more than one million dollars of revenue
through the software platform
including in-app purchases the field
will remain 30 for developers who sales
through the app stores excluding
commissions payments exceed 1 million so
this is for folks that are below a
million meaning the reduction won't
affect such
vocal apple opponents as video game
company epic games
fy like aka fortnite right
yeah which we talked about that before
apple's 30 takes
has uh been at the heart of complaints
this year from other tech companies and
some other users
over how it manages the vast digital
world of people who uses
iphone ipads pretty much they're you
know a monopoly there with this world
but
what are your thoughts about what apples
would go from 30 to 15. this is
something that we covered
a few months ago when fortnite came out
with that uh not fortnite epic games the
owner of
fortnite came out with that sick
commercial kai i don't know if you want
to pull that up where they basically
used apple's infamous commercial from
sick commercial sick commercial to take
a shot at him took a ridiculous shout
out basically
put this whole story on the map yeah i
mean we weren't talking about the story
prior to that
they put the story on the map now since
then we've seen uh
tim apple aka tim cook have to show up
in front of congress as well as jack
dorsey and mark zuckerberg and
especially
big tech in congress and now basically
what apple did was says you know what
here's the commercial um and then the
guy throws the
the unicorn shaped um a fortnight at
apple
yeah that's a brilliant move essentially
what they've been accused of is the
the big the app store monopoly right so
they're monopolizing
you know uh these developers that are
coming on the website are on the on the
app store now
obviously there's been big tech
regulation we've seen this happen
everyone in congress um but what i think
they've done is essentially
let me read this for you viewers that
haven't seen this epic games has defied
the app store monopoly in retaliation
apple is blocking fortnite from a
billion devices
join the fight to stop 2020 from
becoming 1984.
very phenomenal are they still not on
the app store
they're still not on the app store wow
okay yeah they're still not on the app
store clearly a sick commercial
clearly spawned just everyone being like
all right what the hell is going on here
so what i think apple did
here was sort of say all right we're
getting a lot of hate we're getting a
lot of uh
haters out there so let's self-regulate
before congress or anyone steps in
so i've got some numbers for you so in
worldwide commerce worldwide commerce
apple generated 519
billion dollars 85 of that went to
third parties right so they generated 54
billion in revenue but here what i
thought was interesting
is there's the the number here is one
million so if you make less than one
million in revenue
um you know they charge you 15 if you
make more than a million do you know
what percentage
of apps on the app store generate more
than one million
what percentage yes i'd say 90 yeah a
high high percentage okay
um point two percent wait say that
ask the question what percentage of apps
on the app store generate
more than one million dollars what
percentage generates more than a million
dollars there's only point two percent
that's according to an australian
journal yes what percentage of
apps yes yes the question is what
percentage of
revenues comes to them from those less
than a million dollars that's the real
question
because there's a lot of ghetto there
you go 92 percent here's the number
exactly
92 of apple's revenue comes from
these companies that make more than a
million dollars yep 0.2
not 2 0.2 percent um comes from
apps that generate more than a million
dollars there's 1.
1.8 million apps on the app store yeah
but that's and a small small small
percentage of it is essentially
generating
more than a million dollars that's all
that's all it is so basically yeah
the big dogs who are making all the
money the big dogs they're going to
continue to pay
they're not affected they're going to
have to pay they're going to be fine and
then all the small little apps which is
essentially
1.7999 of the 1.8 million apps
are going to pay 15 percent you got
something else this here's what it is
it's a good data right there by the way
it's a slum lord lowering rent on low
income housing
that's all it is he's not touching the
rent on the penthouse why do you have to
you don't have to right three things
that apple isn't known for being
charitable
being stupid and losing money okay so
clearly there's a pr move this is all it
is
because the average person is going to
think oh wow apple's thinking about me
the little guy but it's a math problem
that's all it is
they're not nothing's changed as far as
their revenue let me tell you what my
concern is i'm gonna tell you what my
concern is here's what my biggest
concern is i'm being very sincere about
this
everybody knows i'm an apple guy okay we
got you we got an apple yesterday right
everything to us is apple we love apple
there's apple there there's apple here
there's apple here
this isn't an apple commercial though no
no this is not an apple commercial what
i'm trying to say is i'm a pro
apple guy but i'm going to tell you what
scares the hell out of me with this
so think about what uh
twitter and facebook so twitter perfect
example we haven't even talked about
this by the way it's not even on the
story i don't know why we didn't add it
to the story
uh jack dorsey comes out and says what
we made a mistake we should have let
that new york historic
story go well they knew if they would
have posted allowed that story to go
that would have gotten a few hundred
million views that day right if they
would have let that story go
but now he says what i apologize we did
the wrong thing a week after election
okay a week after election he says that
the power
these big corporations are starting to
have is a little too much
a little too much and i'm all capitalism
but watch what happens here
here's my biggest concern apple comes
out with the iphone 12
right i got it it's the 512 i'm gonna
give away nine of these right now got it
that's it
it's the brand new looking at it right
there this is the brand new one we get a
look here let me get a look
this is the brand well you got to take
it out to see what it looks like with
the new iphone if you take the thing out
just to kind of see what they did to the
body because that's what the difference
is
okay if you take this out if i can't
take it out i've been got to hit the
weights a little bit more lately man
this is
so they went back to the old phone but
look at the
what it is is the round thing is gone
and you know by the way it still breaks
paul bought it the next day he broke it
so it still breaks so if you drop it
you're still going to break your shout
out to paulo scarcely got for breaking
his new iphone
um but the point with this is
my concern is where's blackberry where's
droid
where's the google phone there is no
competition look what's happened here
if i wanted i'm like hey can you get
your phone i'm gonna do an airdrop oh
i'm droid bro can you get on iphone
you have to get an iphone i can't do
airdrop to you
i send a text i put a thumbs up on it
you ever done a thumbs up for somebody
that has droid it comes back and message
wasn't received
why not it happens to eric all the time
that's what the message it comes
you want to facetime a droid you can't
do it there are you want to do an itunes
download you can do
you want to go to a movie you do shazam
shazam takes you to itunes
everything goes to all roads lead
to apple which is absolutely scary
because if apple doesn't like you
and they decide to take a fortnight out
they can afford to do that
and there's nothing you can say about it
why because it's in a place like this
where capitalism needs some work meaning
you apple's getting to the point of
monopoly apple's getting to the point of
control and this is where somebody's got
to get involved because
there is no choices so any they can do
anything they want to do today they can
get away with murder today if they
wanted to
because we don't have that many choices
so my biggest concern isn't the fact
that they're saying
you know good for them if it's like
being progressive tax is what they're
doing the more money you make the more
taxes you pay
so they just came up with a new
progressive tax to say the smaller
earners
pay less taxes and quite frankly if
you're making a million
say you're doing 900 000 in apps you
were paying 30
which is what 270. now you're going to
pay 15 which is what
135. that additional 135 goes to you
what does that 135 pay you
either three employees or an additional
135 in your pocket it's a good amount
for people doing less than a million
dollars
but it's not going to do anything to
their revenues at the top so
my only concern apple's getting a little
too strong you know if you're going to
be a monopoly like an apple potentially
you better have the best product so
thank god they do at least for that no
questions and the other thing that you'd
be concerned with the monopoly is the
pricing but at least the iphone 12 came
down a little right
so and the other right in the iphone 12
it was a decent price compared to the
11.
it wasn't that part of the story i mean
this was still 1500 bucks so but this is
a 512. so i don't know
if it's still if it's gone down or not
you know and then
apple right now has twitter and facebook
running cover for them because
congress is more concerned about their
censorship and the things that they're
doing
with the social media as opposed to
apple they might be able to get away
with
forming a monopoly where the justice
department won't be looking at them
because they have bigger fish to fry in
silicon valley with these other clients
you know you know how they said what
comes first the chicken of the
egg okay who needs who more google needs
is it google
is it apple is it amazon or is it
what's the other one is it facebook
facebook who needs who more so
apple facebook amazon or google
which comes first most people are
getting all that stuff from their phone
so you would say that apple is the you
have to get
keeper that is so dangerous for
everything else you have to understand
i'm gonna get something on
amazon
what i'm trying to say to you that's
what's scary by the way google pays
apple 13 billion dollars every year to
be on their phone
google pays apple 13 bill just to check
hey apple did you know that 13 billion
and maybe higher right now yeah
does that include for chrome for being
on they pay 13 billion just for
their chrome for their stuff to be on
there 13 billion guess what apple's
going to do every year
15 billion 20 billion guess what no no
let's negotiate no
20 billion right you can't say nothing
because the chicken or the egg that that
apple is but you know what that is so
much better than safari they have to
keep having chrome
on there i don't like safari i don't
know if i disagree with you but i don't
think the answer is they have to
nothing with apple right now is they
have to but the fact that they're doing
this i think this is a sign in the right
direction
the fact that they're doing this this is
a little bit of a sign in the right
direction the fact that they're going
from 30 to 15
you can't all of a sudden go say
somebody's giving you a billion dollars
of revenues oh we're going to go to 15
i'm going to get now half a billion
dollars who the hell is going to do that
but the fact that they're doing this
they're trying to get the small
developers to still want to come and
build apps on this
on their platform which i don't know but
i'm telling you guys right now apple's
getting a little too so people are
worried about amazon
all roads lead to apple but doesn't this
further your argument a little bit about
the monopolization of this company
because
yeah by lowering that they're going to
attract everybody why wouldn't you go to
apple if you were somewhere else
but but you mean if you're an app
developer yeah you're going there let me
ask you this let me ask you this if
you're watching this right now i'm
actually curious to know how many guys
don't use an apple phone i don't care
what phone it is just say
i don't use an iphone and what kind of
phone it is you use just type it below
and say i don't use an apple phone i use
samsung i use droid i use what else is
there
droid samsung google uh uh
what is it lg huawei lg i'm cute what is
the second best one in the world right
now is it
that was essentially my my question is
we talked about the monopoly here
if you're not using apple what are you
using what are you using over there
mario
apple okay if you're not using apple
what are you using so i'm glad you asked
that question and then my second
question would be on tax is this going
to be
and i don't know if we have this answer
but something we can maybe uncover is
is the is this 15 versus 30 is that
going to be a marginal
tax bracket meaning if you pay if you
make 1.1 million dollars is your first
million taxed at 15 percent yeah then
you're going to then you're next hundred
that's what they tax at 30
they're not going to bump you up of
course that's what they're going to do
they're going to have to go your first
million at 30 million and then
they didn't do that what a shady system
they wouldn't they would get so much
backlash if they do it in that way kai
what are your thoughts on that man that
marginal tax bracket
you learned about that the other day
yeah you asked why would i want to make
more money if i pay more in taxes you
know norwegians don't know what
guacamole
apple needs to is do you guys not miss
the flip phone because don't you need a
dramatic way to end a conversation you
can't do that anymore
tapping the off button is nice
by the way i had the netflix i should do
it so hard that i would break it mine
was always the one that would hang up do
you know what i'm talking about
why that many people pissed you off
every day you were a lot more aggressive
back then oh
that was the thing you did not even want
to know but okay here we go this is what
people are saying by the way
a lot of people apparently don't use it
okay samsung google pixel
um uh let's see here i don't uh
xiaomi xiaomi xiaomi i don't know what
that's android samsung
samsung samsung's i use an android
huawei
uh android samsung samsung galaxy 20
apple is virus free xiaomi what is
xiaomi by the way i use xiaomi
xiamoi have you heard of i had that
phone
can you pull it up i have no idea what
that is one guy is stuck here in 1998 he
says he use
aol instant messenger good luck with
that guy i think she's going to go to
experts
i a omi what is this
chinese brand wow okay
it's like a huawei put click on images
yeah i've never heard of this this is
great i mean i love seeing competition
there's lots of uh samsung
uh uh apple sucks okay good i like
seeing that i like people saying apple
sucks i hope you stay to that
and i hope andrew so there's to be some
competition i'm hoping android is not
sitting there behind closers and guys we
can't compete with these guys it's over
i'm hoping they're not saying it's over
and they're probably not right i mean as
big as they are i
i don't know about that because i'm not
seeing it by the way if you're watching
this
do you think a another competitor is
going to come and give apple a run for
their money if yes put thumbs up if no
thumbs down this could have a lot of
thumbs down with this one if you think
they are put thumbs up if you don't
think put thumbs down
what's it going to change by the way
people actually miss you people actually
missing thank you guys
she loves you yeah i was surprised
what's it going to take for you to get
back to your old blackberry days
if blackberry does something creative it
would be but at this point
the business model of phone if you want
to compete with apple you have to do one
thing you can't just say
let's build a better phone than this
that's not going to work we have to
build a better net
what do i need so think about it this
way
what do you use the most like microsoft
word do you use that a lot what do you
use a lot use microsoft outlook use
microsoft what things do you use that's
a form of a net
yeah do you use google email google
drive
what do you mean i think i think
google's the greatest invention in the
history of mankind i mean gmail
and the search engine i don't know how
you could possibly live without it
okay so but google has to go more than
that it's got to be music it's got to be
movies like
it's got to be something more than that
i don't like if amazon came out and
their app
is linked to amazon and movies and if
you bought amazon's phone
and then but apple has too big of a head
start there's no way because of app
store because of their their uh
uh this is this is by the way this is
creating content i mean look you buy the
the phone's been the same phone for a
long time they just keep
adding more cameras to the back it's
like oh we got more cameras and it's
faster every time
i buy it yeah like okay i'm a loyalist
so i keep buying it but what about the
5g can you tell a huge difference yes
speed is insane
this is 5g yeah speed is insane i'm not
going to lie to you it's so
fast and i to me i feel the speed it's
very good it was the first year you had
an apple phone
an iphone i never i said i'm the guy
that said i would never flip to an
iphone until this one guy came to my
office i
remember his name here in a minute he
came to my office and says let me tell
you
10 minutes why i need to own an iphone
and i said okay tell me so i was trying
to do business with he says here's why
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
i said man he's just got a great
argument what year was that this was in
2007 was 2018
no 2007. okay right that's my point it's
only 2008.
it's only been 12 13 years so since i'm
an apple guy yeah it hasn't been decades
and decades and now
what was your favorite that's a quarter
of my life you know listen i had an
apple
i had an apple macbook in 1995.
so i've had the computer since the mid
90s i i had a blind iphone though the
iphone i didn't want to switch i used to
be a blackberry guy and i was afraid
i just thought i'd never pick it up and
it took like one day uh 2012 probably
2012. i don't know 2010. i'm losing my
memory i don't know
10 years ago something like that yeah
okay all right i remember with the with
the switch was occurring in in
the late two you know 2007 2008-ish
you had friends started popping up with
iphones like oh check this out i'm like
buddy blackberry what are you talking
about and then
by the way people rest in peace people
don't think
there's going to be competition for
apple did you notice that people don't
think there's going to be i agree with
them
i think it's too tough wow they'll
squash them i trust capitalism i just
think the government's got to get
involved here to say hey you guys got a
monopoly we've got to break it apart
they got to get involved here this is
you think the government's the only way
you could
break it apart remember what i'm not a
fan of like people think i'm a fan of
i'm not a fan of bullies okay the moment
a company becomes too big of a bully
not a fan of that i don't mind bullying
bullies
but i have a problem when the bully is
bullying the little guy
i don't like that when that's what's
taking place right
so right now you know apple can kind of
uh go out there and bully a lot of
people
are foreign i'm not questioning that i'm
saying even
questioning what i find humorous is that
apple was the little startup yeah it
could you know but they're now
so big well david versus glide sometimes
david becomes goliath well exactly
that's
but my point the mindset of it david
that's why they keep growing yeah
they think like a david they still think
they're nobody they still think they're
the small guy they're
awesome but they're playing the offense
in a way that's
the game the game is uh being won by
them so
look there's crony capitalism that makes
capitalism look bad
there's monopoly that makes capitalism
look bad okay and this is one of those
situations this is not crony capitalism
this is a monopoly
you know what i think a huge asset for
apple is i think tim cook is likable
he doesn't come across as a bully yeah i
mean they're front and center seats
jobs dude oh totally not tim cook they
took pride in it as well but here's hook
is the opportunity you're right here's a
guy that
disagrees with 95 of trump's policies
and he goes and works with trump i don't
know anybody on that side
he just goes and says hey would you like
to help us launch the new mac well yeah
sure trump goes
i'd like to come and help the government
out i'd like to come because let's sit
down and talk
how do you do you got a strategic
thinker yeah
was he going to war with the president
united states it's called
setting aside your emotions buddy